[Music]
hello
hello everyone and welcome come on come
on home hi
is
foreign
[Applause]
my
me
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
i
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
without further ado please join me to
welcome managing director hong kong
disneyland resort stephanie
[Music]
thank you scarlett and jessica thank you
so much financial secretary paul chan
eliza kevin
joe peyton distinguished guest
ladies and gentlemen i am so proud to be
here today and celebrate with you all
the launch of ant-man and the wasp nano
battle
we have such amazing key partners from
the government
from disney both from marvel our
wonderful walt disney imagineering team
vip guest
some of the biggest
marvel fans in the world are here let's
give them a hand
[Applause]
ant-man and the wasp nano battle will
officially open to our guests this
sunday march 2 31st this will cement
hong kong disneyland as an ultimate
marble hub in asia
very exciting this high-energy high-tech
experience and interactive adventure
will immerse our guests in a marble
universe
as they answer to iron man
a call to defend hong kong from that
evil hydra so we believe that heroes
here at hong kong disney land come in
all sizes
and that is why ant-man and the wasp
nano battle will be a hit with guests of
all ages especially our young adults and
we're just getting started our
multi-year expansion plan underscores
our commitment to continue to grow hong
kong disneyland
and be
an amazing contribution to this
community in fact we have an amazing
level of confidence in hong kong
disneyland as an international tourist
destination
as part of this new expansion plan we
are bringing even more disney characters
and stories to life in the coming years
as you may have noticed our castle is
undergoing an incredible transformation
that i am so excited about
we are thrilled to continue to bring
even more marvel stories to hong kong
disneyland resort in the future and we
are going to have so much fun today
and we've got a lot in store for you
so you will hear from some of the very
talented people that helped to bring
this magic to all of us
and i've been told that you are going to
get a chance to be one of the first ones
to ride this new attraction
so thank you everyone and enjoy the rest
of your day
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please travis
welcome the financial secretary of the
hong kong special administrative region
the honorable mr paul chan
[Music]
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
i'm delighted to be here once again at
hong kong disneyland
just 10 months ago i opened the seoul
oana
a homecoming celebration
and here i am once again
to welcome ant-man and the vibes to hong
kong
i'm not saying this is better than
giving the budget speech
but i don't recall meeting any superhero
that morning at the legislative council
building
with all the due respect to mr raj
this is much bigger than
we are here today
to formally launch ant-man and devops
nano battle
this high-tech interactive adventure is
the first adventure
and first marvel attraction based on the
ant-man and devops movie at any disney
film park in the world
it is also brilliantly linked
to hong kong disneyland's iron man
experience
true seekers myself include of course
get to join the ant-man
the warps and the iron man
as they battle
it out
with hydra
and swan bombs
in the defense of hong kong
the adventures state-of-the-art gaming
features are cinematic in scope
production
and storytelling not surprising given
that ant-man director peyton reed
and his movie production team
helped in producing
this attraction
and that paul run
and
eventually eventually
also devops
also start in disney
disneyland's nano battle
what makes this innovative experience
even more anointing
is the local story line created
just for hong kong disneyland
and down the road i know there will be
more marvel superheroes to marvel over
creating asia's
ultimate cup
of exciting marvel experiences
at hong kong disneyland in the years to
come
hong kong disneyland has been a major
tourist attraction since it opened back
in 2005
attracting more than 77 million visitors
from all over the world
today here to enjoy the disney magic
that in turn has brought significant
economic benefits
and employment opportunities for tourism
related businesses
the disney magic will continue to bring
us
famous attractions
including a
reimaginative castle
with new stage souls
and a noble film
a novel film area
featuring the princess elsa
and anna
from mecca hit movie frozen
hong kong's expanding ties with the
mainland of china including the opening
of the hong kong drive bridge
and the hong kong section
of the high-speed railway between hong
kong shenzhen and hong
and guangzhou southern and hong kong
will create new markets
and also new friends for the hong kong
disneyland
even more so as the vast guangdong hong
kong macaulay bay area development
comes together
over the years and decades
you thought ladies and gentlemen
ends and marks
as hong kong's
rewarding connections continue to grow
so too few hong kong disneyland
together
we will excel
together we will also vanish
solar and the swamp box
i look forward to that in just a few
minutes
thank you very much indeed
[Music]
i have the pleasure to welcome a very
special guest the director of the hit
films man edmund and the walls
as well as a collaborator on our brand
new attraction and man and squad's nano
battle ladies and gentlemen paige and me
[Applause]
thank you scarlett for the introduction
and uh thank you to walt disney parks
and resorts for the incredible
opportunity to extend
our ant-man and the wasp story even
further than we could on film
um because now all of you get to step uh
into our world and help ant-man and the
lost defeat the evil art of zola before
he infiltrates shields data core now um
i hope you don't mind but i would like
to introduce a couple of uh friends who
play key roles
in this amazing attraction um
one of them the first could not be here
in person with us but she sent along a
very special video message just for you
ladies and gentlemen
here she is the wasp herself
evangeline lilly
and hello everybody at the launch
ceremony
i am
disappointed that i can't be there with
you in person i would love to be there
but i'm stuck here in montreal in the
snow shooting a new movie but i'm so
excited about the grand opening of nano
battle and that you guys are going to be
the first ones to ride it that is so
cool paul peyton and i are sure that you
guys are going to have a blast stepping
into our world and helping us to defeat
arnhem zola every detail of this ride
was created with your joy and excitement
in mind so please have fun and send me
all your reactions on instagram i'm
dying to hear what you think of it i
guess that's it for now until next time
bye everybody bye peyton
let's hear it for eventually
um
as you can see in the footage there uh i
was eventually calling myself on the set
of ant-man of the last nano battle um
and now uh please
welcome me uh
enjoy and uh welcoming my good friend i
think he's my good friend you have to
ask him um
my good friend ant-man
himself incredibly talented
paul run
[Applause]
[Music]
you are my good friend please please
please okay it's
better than okay hi everyone
i have to tell you it is such a thrill
to be here at uh hong kong disneyland
we're very excited hey have you had the
note t yet oh yeah no it's kind of
life-changing absolutely yeah
where do you get an egg tart did you
yeah yeah um hey paul check it out
listen we're getting ready to unveil for
the first time
ant-man and the wasp nano battle yes
finally this this is huge yeah i know it
is huge but but it's really ultimately
all about uh getting small
right you are guess what
guess what what's that peyton guess what
what is that paul
i finally impressed my kids
wait wait wait you just weren't
impressed that you were the star of your
own movie
uh no not at all
or that you're now an avenger
couldn't care less
but now that i'm an attraction
at hong kong disneyland my kids they
finally think i'm cool
[Applause]
well i'd like to say and i think the
audience would agree with me um
you are cool
thank you
that's what i've always told people um
but let me just tell you how uh how much
of angeline and i just loved working on
this amazing attraction with such an
amazing team
and
being part of the marvel universe too
it's been an incredible experience and
we cannot wait for all of you to enjoy
[Applause]
thank you for being here with us today
and now ladies and gentlemen the time
has come to officially launch our marvel
themed attraction but first we need a
little help from our friends
please give a warm welcome to
permanent secretary for commerce and
economic development miss eliza lee
and also please welcome back to the
saints jessica tran
stephanie young and the honorable mr
paul chan
[Applause]
[Music]
all right at this time please take your
positions and console for our final
moment
[Music]
together you will hit those red buttons
to trigger our official opening
alright are you guys ready
on three
one
two
three
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen ant-man and the
lost nana battle begins
at this time our friends from the media
are invited to take photos of our
special guests and our men invite all
the customers on stage to look at the
media at the back of the theater
with a big smile
[Music]
i know it's like the